Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Buonasera ancora!
Provate a pensare, tutti quanti,
per un attimo
a un progetto che avete realizzato
e di cui vi siete sentiti orgogliosi.
Non importa [che fosse] una cosa grande
o piccola, una cosa media.
l’importante è
che ci abbiate pensato, riflettuto,
sviluppato la vostra idea,
compiuto diversi passaggi
e poi siate arrivati a una fine.
Non so se ci avete fatto caso
ma molto spesso,
quando parliamo di realizzare
i nostri progetti,
utilizziamo termini
come avvicinarsi alla meta
o camminare un passo dopo l’altro,
mettere un piede davanti all’altro,
o anche usare le proprie gambe,
inteso come farcela
con le proprie abilità.
Sembra quindi che il camminare,
questa attività lenta
e ripetitiva, sempre uguale,
ci porti ad avvicinarsi,
a raggiungere i nostri sogni.
Qui è dove il mio camminare
in giro per il mondo
e in diversi laboratori sparsi
in continenti lungo tutto il pianeta
mi ha portato oggi.
Al Biodesign Lab
dell’Università di Harvard
realizziamo esocheletri composti
da tessuti indossabili
che possano aiutare
le persone a camminare.
Esoscheletro, questa parola “tecnica”,
significa appunto scheletro esterno,
e come potete vedere
dalla nostra slide, qui,
abbiamo uno dei test
che svolgiamo all’interno del laboratorio.
Studiamo come le persone camminano,
studiamo il movimento delle persone,
per riuscire a progettare
questi strumenti
che appunto aiutano
le persone a camminare.
Dobbiamo avere una conoscenza
del nostro tipo di cammino.
Questo è il nostro esocheletro.
È composto da tessuti indossabili,
vedete nelle foto di destra,
e si mette veramente
come un paio di pantaloni, è una tuta.
E grazie a due motori
che vedete attaccati allo zaino
e collegati con dei cavi alle gambe,
riesce appunto a fare che sì
che la persona
possa andare in giro
grazie a un aiuto esterno.
Il sistema è composto semplicemente
da pantaloni, motori e cavi.
Lo zaino che vedete nelle foto
è stato semplicemente uno strumento
per attaccare i pantaloni
ed è nel caso vuoto.
Il sistema stesso
è dotato di sensori intelligenti
che riescono a capire
i vari eventi del ciclo del passo.
Riescono quindi a capire
se la mia gamba sta atterrando,
oppure se la mia gamba
è in fase di spinta.
E in base a questo non fanno altro
che fornire la corretta spinta
alle persone che ne hanno bisogno.
Potete intuire che l’applicazione
di questi sistemi è enorme.
E tutte le persone
che hanno bisogno
di avere quella che in gergo
si chiama una camminata aumentata
possono beneficiare di questi sistemi.
Pensate a persone con mobilità ridotta,
persone che hanno avuto
una emiparesi, una paresi,
anziani, persone per esempio
che devono trasportare grossi carichi.
Nella foto vedete appunto uno zaino
perché stavamo svolgendo
un esperimento di questo tipo.
Potrebbero essere forze dell’ordine,
quindi soldati;
potrebbero essere escursionisti,
e qualsiasi altra persona
che voi possiate pensare
abbia bisogno di una camminata aumentata.
La possibilità di realizzare
una camminata aumentata
è stato uno dei sogni dell’umanità
per anni ed anni.
Tanto per citarvi un esempio,
alla fine del 1800,
e quindi potete immaginarvi
lo stato tecnologico della fine del 1800,
è stato brevettato
il primo esoscheletro di arto inferiore.
Da questo “nonno”, diciamo così,
del nostro sistema,
si arriva ad oggi a questo
che riesce invece a ridurre
l’energia che usiamo
mentre camminiamo.
Quindi utilizzando il nostro sistema
che spinge le gambe in sincrono
con il mio movimento,
riesco ad utilizzare meno dell’energia
che normalmente uso per camminare.
Ovviamente dal brevetto del 1800 ad oggi,
per arrivare ad Ironman,
di strada ce n’è ancora molta da fare.
Però...
se fare in modo che avere
una camminata aumentata
sia uno dei sogni dell’umanità,
possiamo per caso riuscire
a fare il contrario?
Possiamo cioè fare sì
che siamo capaci
di raggiungere i nostri sogni
con le nostre gambe?
Quello di cui vi ho parlato adesso
è stato ed è tuttora uno dei miei sogni.
Poter lavorare in quest’area,
in questo laboratorio
e riuscire, o contribuire
a creare un tipo di strumento
che possa essere d’aiuto
per moltissime persone.
Nel mettere insieme
questa presentazione per il TED
ho pensato allora un po'
agli anni passati
e ho pensato alle cose
che mi hanno ispirato
e che mi sono state d’aiuto
durante il mio percorso,
durante il mio cammino fin qui.
E mi fa piacere provare
a condividerle con voi oggi
attraverso cinque parole
che spero potranno essere
di aiuto e ispirazione
anche per altri.
La prima per me è la passione.
Se non c’è la passione
non si va da nessuna parte.
Mettete passione nelle cose che fate,
e soprattutto spendete del tempo
a capire veramente
quali sono le vostre passioni.
Cosa vi piace fare veramente.
Non fatevi trovare in situazioni
precostituite, preconfezionate,
in cui siete costretti a fare sempre,
comunque la stessa cosa.
Senza la possibilità di cambiare strada
lungo il vostro cammino.
Appassionatevi alle cose
e cercate altre persone come voi
che siano appassionate,
in modo da poter condividere
le stesse passioni.
La seconda per me è fatica.
Che poi è anche veramente,
strettamente collegata alla prima
tanto da essere un po' la stessa cosa.
Non esiste la possibilità, per me,
di realizzare un sogno
senza mettere della fatica.
Fatica intesa come sacrificio,
voglia e disponibilità
di rinunciare a certe cose
per arrivare a un grande obiettivo.
La terza è consapevolezza.
Siate consapevoli delle vostre abilità,
delle vostre capacità, le possibilità
- ma anche, e soprattutto,
dei vostri limiti.
Decidete voi dove fissare l’asticella,
e poi dovete solo raggiungerla.
La quarta è riflessione.
Soprattutto oggi in cui
si deve sempre fare, fare,
fare un sacco di cose, fare di tutto.
Penso che sia molto importante
ogni tanto fermarsi a pensare.
Non necessariamente pensare
al vostro obiettivo
o a quello che dovete fare
per raggiungerlo;
ma semplicemente
fermarsi un attimo e riflettere
spendendo un po' di tempo
con se stessi.
Se poi avete anche la possibilità
di arrivare fin lassù,
beh c’è anche una bella vista...
L’ultima sono le radici.
Penso che molti di voi
riconosceranno questo posto.
Quel bambino non so
se lo riconoscete, però sarei io.
Penso che le radici
siano molto importanti,
perché vi mostrano
da dove siete partiti.
Voi tenete sempre gli occhi fissi
dritti davanti al vostro obiettivo
ma con la coda [dell’occhio]
guardate da dove siete partiti.
Le radici vi mostrano
quanta strada avete fatto
per arrivare dove siete oggi
e vi dicono quello che siete veramente.
Quello che siete diventati,
la vostra identità sono le vostre radici.
Spero che oggi,
alla fine di questa giornata,
tutti voi possiate uscire da qui,
dopo avere ascoltato queste presentazioni
e aver visto diverse cose
e pensare veramente a quello
che volete fare nella vita.
E magari, già oggi, fare
il primo passo per realizzarle.
Grazie.
(Applausi)